We've seen distribution with one radical, let's try multiply two binomials
together. These binomials contain a radical in each one. This one has the
square root of 2 and this one has the square root of 7. When we multiply two
binomials, we want to distribute each term in the first parentheses to each
term in the second parentheses. So we'll multiply 3 times 2 and 3 times root 7,
and then we'll multiply root 2 times 2, and root 2 times root 7. We want to
simplify any radicals that we can and combine like terms if possible. So try
this one out, and don't worry if you don't get it right on your first try. We
haven't even done one like this. If you think back to multiplying polynomials
though, you just might figure it out. Good luck.